i mean yeah i would never go into
fighting never hell no
how much would they have to pay
chappelle for me to go into fighting
how much did nate robinson make gin
that's a great question yeah let's hear
that and then i'll answer that
i bet he made seven hundred thousand
tim would you fight anybody is that good
yeah i don't think
how much yeah yeah tell me that number a
million that's it
there you go nate robinson made 600.
wait six hundred dollars like flat
well you gotta pay your dreams how much
did he make
six six hundred dollars each that can't
be right no
that's two different websites yeah what
that's crazy yeah no from the back end
though i've written so once the
pay-per-views come in they'll get that
badou jack made 180k yeah because
tyson's pro
this is somewhere chicken tyson
uh supposed to make 10 mil guarantee
joan's supposed to make 3 million
guaranteed
paul yeah i'm sure it has to be back and
that's weird 600
don't make sense no you know but maybe
they just put them on the card
like we get we'll give you a percentage
of the pay-per-view pay-per-view does
well you boys can get paid
oh yeah yeah on the back because
obviously oh
they got the money signed
[Music]
how many pay-per-view buys oh it's not
out yet okay i'll keep checking though
look at this look at this pathetic look
at these drunk they look like two of my
drunk uncles and
in their underwear go up check it out it
looks like it looks like my two uncles
at a barbecue fight
i thought stupid i thought soup was
funny okay what's your problem
yeah you know you know the ufc tried him
out on the contender series
yeah and he got fired after like two
episodes why
because he kept making those kind of
jokes and it's not
like dude the contender series is like
young
talent like real [ __ ] and snoop doesn't
know fighting we all love snoopy there's
no [ __ ] fighting so he's making fun
of the guys when they lose they get
knocked out you know and you just can't
have it
like it's not entertainment it's a
serious thing yo but it works for this
because it was it was entertainment
yeah and that's why it worked i think
him and tyson had the same career you
remember when
snoop dogg went to rapid hardcore hip
hop guy and we
his first like what we just started
acting with baby boy but
he starts training today but we start
seeing uh snoop in the playful light
when he got on that cooking show
martha stewart martial yeah well stoop
commercials soup crossed over into like
regular like celebrity like everyone
knows snoop now yeah everyone knows
everything everyone loves
with the high got his g gg network yeah
yeah his podcast so yeah i think that's
i kind of like snoop i like
i love steve she's one of my favorite
people okay well i'm just saying it was
it was it was only right for him to
commentate this fight i think you think
yeah 100 percent i think yeah i thought
he was going to go so this one
especially sports.com says
600 000 each which would make more sense
yes yeah but uh no it's not enough
that's not enough how much uh you've got
to pay me a million i had someone ask me
how much you would
i said well who would it be against
and then the other thing that's tough is
my background like i fought
professionally
i was writing the topic but she wasn't
professional in boxing though no
which is a golden gloves yep but it
doesn't matter you got fans
would you fight now i know we are big
fans of the paul brothers come on the
show we love you
i'm too big for them you're too big for
them too big i'm heavyweight you have to
pick another heavyweight guy oh wait
they're not
i'd have to fight like terry crews what
what what would you like to tear away
i bought the [ __ ] up takers but you'd
have to pay me 10 mil what about the guy
from uh
what would you fight aquaman oh my
yeah too good looking again he's great
no way hi what i'm just saying i fight
the rock
i'm kind of intrigued today
i would absolutely dismantle the rock
listen he's on steroids
you don't think i'm gonna get on servers
we gotta test this system
how many rounds how many rounds eight
two minute rounds okay two minute rounds
boxing yeah it has to be boxing i don't
know where i got distance
i would beat the bra you would beat the
brakes off where would you go what was
your biggest problem thank you
six four i've been elevating price six
four
one of us is going to pass the drug test
and his name ain't the rock
so he's 65. he ain't six five he's not
no i've been elevated with him he had
his heels on what's your game plan talk
to us yeah yeah because i'm kind of
curious i mean i would
jab the piss out of his moana nose for
four rounds and then
light his ass up with the right hand do
we have any like footage of rock just
like hitting the bag
yeah let's get that picture brendan i
don't know yeah he's a bunch
he's jack because he put you in that
like hole like clutch
with the gloves on he goes oh you're
exhausted yeah
no he's swole there's no doubt about it
that man is swole
see a rock sparring oh this is the right
oh this is anthony joshua oh yeah okay
he's showing something
rocking me real stiff yeah
oh
look at kevin hart good to see you
brother
you all right good to see you champion
of the world big fight coming up what's
going to be pounding
i don't want to cut you off is that is
that how you roll your shoulder you know
relax
you pop that first joke oh that's a
[Applause]
when i see something wrong i can't keep
it to myself
what you need to do is focus on the foot
okay i didn't hear you say anything
about a foot we're in the fight i'm
stepping on your foot
i got your foot get away ain't no
getting away
with the bags
he said don't take your time out how
about we do this hello kevin i go to the
car
you got your bro so funny yeah bro i
don't know i saw that jab by the rock
brendan that's something that's a strong
knuckle right there
yeah oh come on man all right
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song